وينضم الان الينا من مونتانا مايكل النائب
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق سيد
مروي اهلا بك هذه الحكمه التي يتحدث بها
الرئيس بايدن عن تاخير انضمام اوكرانيا
الى النيتو هل تاتي متاخره بعض الشيء
انا معكم المشكله الان هو انه
كان يمكن ان نضم
لانه ضم اوكرانيا قبل 2014 ولكن تاخير ضمه
الان في حين الحرب مستمره
ستكون قد دخلنا في الحرب مباشره لان
الماده الخامسه تقول انه اذا تم تعرض احد
اعضاء حلفايه الهجوم
فالجميع الدول الاخرى ينبغي ان تهب
لمساعدته
واعتقد انه ما سيتم مناقشته هو ايجاده
طريق لكي يثبت تصبح او تنضم اوكرانيا بعد
انتهاء الحرب
ربما الحديث ايضا عن عن هذه القضيه في هذا
التوقيت يثير التساؤل حول لماذا لم يكن
ذلك منذ البدايه روسيا كانت تطالب ضمانات
امنيه مكتوبه قبل بدء العملياتها العسكريه
كما تسميها في اوكرانيا وطالبت تحديدا
بهذه النقطه عدم ضم عدد من الدول المجاوره
لها الى حلف الناتو الم يكن بالامكان
بالفعل اعطاء روسيا هذه الضمانات قبل كل
ما جرى والان بكل بساطه الرئيس الامريكي
اعلن بانه لن يكون لن يكون هناك انضمام
لاوكرانيا
ما يمكنني ان نقوله العكس روسيا قالت انها
قلقه من توسع حلف الناتو اوكرانيا كانت
تطلب ذلك منذ تسعينات وتم رفضها عده مرات
ولم يسمح لها بالانضمام
وفنلندا والسويد لم ينضم وذلك نتيجه
الغزو الذي قامت به اوكرانيا وما هو ما
جعل فنلندا تنضم وكذلك السويد تتنضم في
حال موافقات
تركيا اذا قبل الغزو لم يكن هناك توسع
لحلف الان هناك توسع وذلك كله بسبب الخطا
الاستراتيجي الذي ارتكبه الرئيس بوتين
بالهجوم على بلد جار ولكن روسيا تعتبر جزء
من هذه الحرب بطريقه او باخرى وان لم يكن
هناك مواجهه مباشره هذه الكلمات التي جاءت
من الرئيس بايدن في السباق القمه التي
تعقد في ليتوانيا هل يمكن ان
تؤدي الغرض بمعنى اخر هل يمكن ان تقنع
بوتين بان الامر قد انتهى وانه ليس هناك
تدخل مباشر من النيتو في هذه المرحله
اذا الى حد الان يمكن هناك تدخل مباشر اذا
نقطه مهمه اثرتها
الولايات المتحده وحلفائه وشركائها قدموا
كميات كبيره من الاسلحه والمعدات والذخيره
لاوكرانيا ولم ندخل المعركه بشكل مباشر
لاننا
هناك شيء سيكون هجوما على احد اعضاء حلف
الناتو مثلا بولندا لكن في الوقت الحاضر
المتحده او حلف الناتو حسب علمي ليس لهم
نيه بالمشاركه في هذه الحرب وسنتحدث عن
الطريق التي يمكن بها لاوكرانيا ان تنضم
لحلف الناتو لان اعمال بوتر هي التي جعلت
الامر ضرووريا ان هذا البلد ينضم الى حلف
الناتو ليحصل على حمايه من مثل هذه من مثل
هذا الغزو مايكل مروي نائب مساعد وزير
الدفاع الامريكي السابق من مونتانا شكرا
جزيلا لك